this is the narrative on kazakh state
television around the clock operation to
catch or kill up to 20 000 so-called
terrorists
responsible for the recent unrest with
seizures of weapons and hard liquor
regretfully peaceful demonstrations in
almaty and some other regions
were hijacked by perpetrators and both
local and external terrorist groups
speaking foreign languages
[Music]
to back those claims state media
broadcast a foreign nationals public
confession
he says he's unemployed and from
kyrgyzstan who accepted from unknown
persons the equivalent of two hundred
dollars and a plane ticket to fly to
almighty and take part in the violence
[Music]
but it's fiction
the man is vikram rozachonov a
celebrated jazz pianist with 27 000 fans
on instagram
we are expressing our outrage that the
kazakh special services and government
are manipulating the kazakh people and
showing kirga's people as enemies
it is really really bad and we are
shocked about it and the vikram is well
known worldwide
what about
people who are not so well known
officially more than 5 000 people have
been detained we worry there could be
torture used against them but also they
should be immediately given access to
lawyers relatives should be able to
visit them there should be people should
know where they are who is in detention
where this is vital for kazakhstan to
have some sort of shred of
adherence with its human rights
commitments
authorities say they're working to get
vikram released
they say he traveled to almaty with his
mother for a music performance
[Music]
there may well be evidence criminal
groups were involved in the violence but
the kazakh authorities appear to have
chosen the wrong man to build their case
robin forrester walker al jazeera